what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with secret Invasion and the
ending of this story is gonna have a
really really cool moment so make sure
you guys stick around and check that out
but what we end up doing here at least
what we're going to do in this video is
we're going to cover how it is the
Scrolls we're able to infiltrate Earth
in the first place and this all happens
because of two people the first is queen
varanki and the second is Spider-Woman
Jessica Drew now there's a few things
that we have to understand in order to
grasp what's going on here so what
really takes place is that you basically
have a meeting between Jessica Drew and
Nick Fury and what Nick Fury literally
does is he tells her like I want you to
find a way to get your powers back and I
want you to find a way to infiltrate
Hydra or at least to use your contacts
with Hydra to effectively become a
double agent now the reason why this
happened goes all the way back to a
couple different stories the first one
was Spider-Woman volume one issue number
50 and the second was Avengers
240-241 and the whole idea behind this
is this is kind of like the Spider Woman
Morgan lafaye story if you guys are
familiar with Morgan lafay she's not
over really important for this the long
and short of it is that Jessica Drew
basically ended up time traveling in
order to go back and defeat Morgan
lafaye but in doing so Morgan lafaye
basically separated the spiritual
essence of Jessica Drew from her
physical body what this meant is that
Jessica Drew believing that she was dead
had actually met with her former Mentor
a guy by the name of Magnus who
basically possessed magical abilities
and so on and had him cast a spell to
trick everybody in the world into
believing she didn't exist and so when
you get into Avengers 240 and 241 the
body of Jessica Drew is discovered and
because nobody remembers who she is they
end up calling on Doctor Strange only
for Stephen Strange to basically find
her spiritual Essence and bring it back
to her body the problem with this is
that she's basically powerless now this
was kind of Marvel's attempt to sort of
rework the character of Jessica Drew at
that point in time but the important
thing here is that following that she
did get her powers back but they
fluctuated right sometimes she had her
Spider Woman powers sometimes she didn't
and so so what she ended up doing was
making a deal with Hydra in order for
her to get her powers back and that
allowed her to really kind of put her in
a position where she had to become an
agent of Hydra spying on shield and so
for those of you guys who have ever read
the history of Jessica Drew that's where
that comes from now Nick Fury figured
this out and that's the basis behind
this meeting is it's basically if you're
a hydro agent working for them now I
know what's going on either I can have
you just killed arrested any number of
things or you could become a double
agent and you can spy on Hydra and feed
them information to me Nick Fury of
course ever the pragmatist and the
director of Shield would certainly go
this route and so Jessica Drew basically
became a double agent now eventually
Hydra is able to restore her powers once
she makes the request and that's the
crazy thing here is because this is
where the secret Invasion kicks off
remember in one of the videos that we
covered we talked about how the secret
Invasion really has its roots in the
idea that the Scrolls saw Earth as kind
of their Manifest Destiny right their
rightful place to rule following the
destruction of their Homeworld by
Galactus the Illuminati visiting the
Scrolls in the first place and kicking
all that off so on and so forth and so
what ends up happening is that when
Jessica Drew's powers are restored what
she doesn't know is the entire Hydra
base is basically composed of Scrolls
that literally this is where they're
making their move it's the person that
Queen varanki chose now Queen varanki
chose Jessica Drew because of her
position because of the fact that she
basically has contacts with virtually
every superpowered being or organization
on Earth in some form or fashion she's
got contacts and Hydra which basically
allow the Scrolls to start replacing
people in Hydra she's got contacts and
shield by way of Nick Fury so they can
start duplicating people she knows the
superhero Community she's the best
person positioned for that and so once
Jessica Drew is put under by these
Scrolls then that's when Queen varanki
makes her move and what they end up
doing is effectively casting a kind of
spell and what it does is it basically
blankets Queen varanki with this sort of
cloth and then it allows them to
manipulate her mind so what you're
talking about here is kind of the
equivalent of sensory deprivation to a
degree right hypnosis or something along
those lines now there is a kind of
difference between what queen varanki is
experiencing as well as what everybody
else is experiencing what queen varanki
is getting is basically dual memories
she's getting the memories of Jessica
Drew but she's also keeping the memories
of herself something that we'll talk
about later on in another video is that
the other Scrolls actually won't get
this that they won't be able to maintain
their own memories and in fact their
memories will be replaced with the
memories of different superheroes but
because of the fact that Queen varanki
is basically leading the charge here
once she's sent back to Earth she
basically ends up calling a meeting of
the various Scrolls who have replaced
humans and various members of the
superhero community at this sort of
Warehouse right there's this docs out by
the Hudson River this really just kind
of Off the Grid and what she does is she
talks about the nature of the superhero
Community as it exists at the moment
right she says right off the bat there's
three main targets that we have to hit
in the first wave now what's ironic
about this is that these are all
basically going to be taken care of for
her in some form or fashion the first
one that they have to hit are the
vibranium mines which basically means
they're going to have to go after the
Savage land in Antarctica and they're
gonna have to go after wakanda and the
reason for that is she said that
vibranium can be used to make weapons
that the Empire cannot fight back
against right it's the only thing on the
planet that we can't combat the other
thing about this is they're really
concerned about the nature of like
mutants and the reason for that and
really what she says is the mutant
population on Earth is exceedingly huge
there's just so many of them and she
literally says now they have an island
they have real estate there are so many
of them if something isn't done to thin
the herd this might all be for nothing a
fight against an army of Earth's mutants
we cannot win now there's a couple
distinctions to understand here the
story of secret Invasion takes place
before both dark rain and house and
powers of X the reason why that matters
is that for those of you guys who are
new to Marvel Comics if you're
experienced it with here but for those
of you guys who are new during the
events of dark Reign what the X-Men did
is they actually fashioned an island for
themselves off the coast of San
Francisco which was known as utopia it
was a really really cool place of course
during house and powers of X by Jonathan
Hickman the X-Men ended up taking up
residence on the mutant nation of
krakowa which became its own Sovereign
Place the island that Jessica Drew was
talking about right now is genocia and
that was the first real mutant Island
that existed for the mutant population
on Earth prior to that all you really
had were things like Magneto's asteroid
M and so on and so forth right Avalon if
you want to call it that that's what it
was called really in the the 90s in
Marvel Comics but the thing about this
is that genocia has largely been just
devoid of a mutant population since
Cassandra Nova sent the wild Sentinels
there and massacred 16 million mutants
in the ES4 Extinction Storyline by Grant
Morrison so that's not really a thing
anymore however Magneto resides there a
few other people reside there but even
with that being the case that genocide
could be a place where mutants could
form a unified front so if the secret
Invasion were to happen like right now
and like the Scrolls were to just invade
Earth the mutant population likely under
the leadership of Magneto would unify in
the remnants of genocia and then be able
to launch a pretty strong attack against
the skrulls so what they need is to thin
the herd now fortunately for them that's
going to be taken care of as well but
the initial plan that they have is
looking at the landscape of Earth and
they come rapidly to this realization
that Humanity hates the mutant
population and so the best way for them
to thin the herd from their perspective
is to actually fan the Flames of human
hatred towards the mutant population so
that way they can kind of have humans
take care of all of it for them right
again operating behind the scenes now
one of the last things they talk about
is going after the actual Illuminati
themselves and this is the flaw in the
plan this is the reason why whenever it
comes to wartime efforts forming wartime
plans things like that you have to leave
a motion at the door Queen varanki
Harbors a particular hatred towards the
Illuminati and so instead of simply
saying like we can just kill ree
Richards right now or we can poison Tony
Stark and take him out of the picture
this instant instead her stance is no
like we're going to take them we're
gonna we're gonna bring them to the
capital city of the scroll Empire
they're going to stand trial for their
actions when they were the Illuminati
and they forced themselves on the scroll
Empire and that's going to be it that's
how they're going to experience their
Justice that's the flaw because it's
basically leaving alive people that
could actually take them out right they
could actually bring the whole thing
down that's why you kind of have to go
through whenever it comes to wartime
plans like this you have to go through
and you have to basically isolate those
individuals that stand the best possible
chance of defeating you leave a motion
to the door and take them out right off
the bat because then what you do without
the Illuminati is you leave the
superhero Community scattered leaderless
and divided there's no unifying front
there anymore and so what ends up
happening is that with her kind of
continuing her role pretending to be
Jessica Drew there's a few things that
happen one she basically meets with with
the new Avengers so that's kind of her
getting her way in but also finding a
way to basically bring in or at least
duplicate Ant-Man Hank Pym but the
second thing that goes on is the Scrolls
orchestrate the the prison break at the
raft now the idea behind this is that
when Brian Michael Bendis first launched
the new Avengers storyline the raft was
the opening story arc and all we knew is
that Electro Maxwell Dylan had basically
taken down power to the whole place he
literally blew up and overloaded the
electrical generators it allowed all
these different villains to escape that
was orchestrated by the Scrolls and the
hope is that it would leave the
superhero Community distracted what it
actually ended up doing is unifying them
because prior to those events you
basically saw the dissolution of the
Avengers and we'll talk about them here
in a second but during the Wrath
storyline you saw Iron Man and Captain
America forming a new Avengers team and
that's their fear is that what they may
have done is actually unified them and
so what you have is when Princess ronke
as Jessica Drew visits Hank Pym who of
course is now a scroll duplicate and the
two of them start talking she comes to
this realization that because Hank pym's
always been overlooked by The Avengers
that he actually has the ability to kind
of operate without anybody really
noticing or paying attention to what it
is that he's doing and it's always kind
of been that way or at least it's been
that way for a long time when it came to
Hank Pym on The Avengers team it wasn't
always that way he was a founding member
of the team and was greatly respected
but due to things like slapping Janet
Van Dyne which didn't really seem that
unique because Reed Richards slapped
Susan's storm around all the time it saw
a lot of the superhero Community losing
a lot of respect for him this was
compiled when he ended up siding with
Reed Richards and Iron Man during the
events of Civil War and so people the
you know those individuals who stood
against Civil War and on the side of
Captain America had lost respect for him
as well and that's the reason why not a
lot of people see him as an honorable
person and so that's cool because what
you end up getting is Jessica Drew who's
officially brought on to the new
Avengers team and so when you go back
and you read and we might go back and
cover it Brian Michael bendis's New
Avengers run the entire time you see
Jessica Drew there she's basically a
scroll she's a queen she's the the
scroll Queen and it changes the way that
you see the story in its entirety it
shifts everything because it's kind of
like all this stuff that she's doing is
all designed to bring down the superhero
Community now one of the things that she
does is when she meets with the new
Avengers team it's their first real
coming together as a group she asks
about where Wanda maximoff is and that's
when everything kind of gets quiet and
it's just sort of like well she
basically had a breakdown this takes
place between Avengers disassembled but
before the events of House of M so what
this means is that at this moment right
now that Wanda is on the mutant island
of genocia basically being cared for by
by Magneto with Xavier trying to find a
way to fix her mind and so what is going
on is that again as she kind of
continues through right Jessica Drew or
at least queen varanki as Jessica Drew
continues on this sort of road and you
know reintegrating herself with a
superhero community and so on and so
forth you of course have director Maria
Hill who's the new director of Shield
following fury secret war and Nick Fury
basically being ousted kind of going
underground that she doesn't trust
Jessica drew that Jessica Drew was at
one point an agent for Hydra and that
because of that the concern of Maria
Hill is that Jessica Drew potentially
still could be so it's just kind of
establishing a lack of trust between the
two of them which is something that will
be important the kicker about all this
is that Hank Pym contacts Jessica Drew
at the moment when the meeting is taking
place on Genosha leading into House of M
that what hengpim tells her is that the
superhero Community the new Avengers a
bunch of the mutants and so on they're
all going to genocia at the request of
Xavier and Magneto and the reason for
that is because in that conversation
this is one of the things that we don't
really cover here in the story but
instead it's just part of House of M
that at the beginning of that story
Xavier had come to the realization there
was no way to fix Wanda's mind there was
no way to to get her back to a normal
State her mind was just too far broken
due to a variety of things right it
wasn't even just the whole idea of
Agatha the Harkness wiping her mind
right here was the fact that she had
been 10 by the power of cathode when she
was a younger kid right the fact that
her she had just experienced all these
chaotic moments over the course of her
life that there just was no way to fix
her and so Xavier ended up bringing
together the new Avengers and the X-Men
to propose the idea that they actually
kill Wanda now of course as we know from
the House of M story what this did is it
led to Quicksilver overhearing the
conversation running to Wanda and then
saying you can fix everything and so
what one they ended up doing was
basically kidnapping Charles Xavier
using her power to scan his mind in
order to understand the subconscious
desires of everybody on Earth and then
rewrote reality and so where him him is
tasked by Princess varanki to still
aboard that ship and to find some way to
stop them from killing Wanda because she
can basically be used as an agent for
the scroll Empire what ends up happening
is because Hank Pym has always been
overlooked the new Avengers and the
X-Men take off without him and so a few
hours later on the mutant island of
genocia Jessica Drew along with
everybody else is whisked Away by Wanda
and transported to the newly created
House of M Universe with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end kind of a crazy Cliffhanger isn't it
thank you all for watching and I will
catch you all later
peace